oubliez l'image des animaux en train de
paître auchan en californie c'est dans
les laboratoires que se conçoivent les
aliments de demain des aliments qui
serait meilleur pour la santé et pour
l'environnement
mais les prétentions de cette industrie
émergente sont elles réalistes
certains se permettent d'en douter
la californie lieu phare de l'innovation
technologique est aussi le berceau de
tendances alimentaires émergents
[Musique]
dans le bond and state la recherche en
matière de protéine alternative est en
ébullition de jeunes entreprises
spécialisées dans ce qu'on appelle la
nourriture 2.0 se multiplient et font
saliver les investisseurs aux poches
profondes
cette nouvelle industrie agroalimentaire
nous a ouvert ses portes
premier arrêt sacramento la capitale
californienne
[Musique]
il faut une nouvelle révolution verte
aujourd'hui ou plutôt une révolution
rouge
pourquoi le plus de viande avec moins de
ressources
paul shapiro vegan pur et dur a presque
signé un pacte avec le diable en créant
de belgique company ont vu offrir une
meilleure viande mais je m'y aider
l'industrie de la viande à réduire son
empreinte environnementale
l'inversion des traités par la suite les
industriels et les campagnes directement
dans la viande
[Musique]
son entreprise fabrique des préparations
de protéines de blé et de fibres
végétales l'industrie agroalimentaire
incorpore se mélangent aux mets à base
de boeuf de porc et de poulet ses
croquettes par exemple sont fait à parts
égales de poulet et du mélange végétales
elles sont vendues dans plus de 7000
supermarchés à travers les états unis
on retient il faut avoir l'audace de
faire les choses autrement
mon prochain arrêt et à san francisco où
de jeunes entrepreneurs audacieux
connaissent justement un immense succès
commercial
just a misé sur un indispensable de la
cuisine les oeufs elle commercialise un
mélange à base de plantes qui imitent
les yeux à la perfection
cuisinier ici anti fixe active dans les
cuisines de just
[Musique]
comme des alchimistes il cherche
l'élément clé qui permettra de
développer le prochain produit vedette
[Musique]
l'ingrédient magique se cache peut-être
ici dans une réserve secrète cachée au
sous-sol de l'entreprise on m'autorise à
aller voir ce qui s'y cache
il s'agit d'un immense coffre fort de
végétaux c'est l'une des plus
importantes collections de protéines
végétales destinées à améliorer la
fonctionnalité des aliments odile azimi
a parcouru la planète pour constituer
cette banque de végétaux ses voyages et
ses recherches ont permis de découvrir
la plante aux capacités émulsifiants tu
qui imite à merveille la texture des
oeufs
cette plante vedette c'est le haricot
mungo le mélange végétal fait avec ses
haricots se compare avantageusement aux
le conventionnel sur le plan
environnemental selon chercheurs notre
mélange à base de haricots mungo
consomme 98% - dos et à une entrée
carbone 94% moins grande et la
production de 85 % de surfaces agricoles
c'est beaucoup plus durable que la
production d'oeufs de consommation
just vient raviver l'intérêt des
agriculteurs pour cette légumineuse
ancien originaire d'inde et déjà
cultivées en amérique du nord
on offre une belle opportunité aux
producteurs ils ont un marché garantit
avec la popularité grandissante de notre
mélange de végétaux just l'entreprise
table aussi sur un projet monumental qui
risque de révolutionner le monde
agricole
la viande en laboratoire ce qui peut
sembler sortir tout droit d'un film de
science fiction fait partie du quotidien
she just c'est ici qu'on isole les
cellules et qu'on sélectionne scène qui
serviront à la production
on est conscient qu'on ne changera pas
des habitudes alimentaires du jour au
lendemain que c'est dérangeant mais il
est notre but en quelques années ou
décennies et de remplacer la production
industrielle de viande
on est ici au carrefour de la biologie
et de l'ingénierie pour fabriquer de la
viande artificielle sans tuer des
animaux
les scientifiques de just ont recours
aux techniques d ingénierie tissulaire
si la méthode peut sembler futuriste
elle somme toute assez simple
le procédé consiste tout d'abord à
prélever des cellules souches de
l'animal ces cellules sont prélevés sur
un bo de muscles de l'animal ici du
poulet puis elles sont ensemencées dans
une solution liquide constitué de
facteurs de croissance et de nutriments
qu'on appelle le milieu de culture
ensuite chauffé et agité en incubateur
les cellules vont grandir proliférer
s'aligner pour former une minuscule
fibre cellulaire et devenir
progressivement du tissu mais pour
espérer changer la face de
l'alimentation avec la viande
artificielle just doit aussi relever
quelques défis de taille
le premier celui du goût j'assiste à la
cuisson d'une croquette dont le prix
s'élève à 50 dollars l'unité
son cas n'est trouvé
où
est
avec quelques bugs
l'entreprise californienne estime
pouvoir mettre ses croquettes de poulet
en marché en 2023 mais elle a d'autres
défis
just doit pouvoir garantir l'innocuité
de son produit il ya un risque que les
cellules cultivées en laboratoire
développe des virus just fait aussi
valoir que l'agriculture cellulaire est
moins énergivore et à une meilleure
empreinte environnementale que l'élevage
industriel ses prétentions ne peuvent
être vérifiés et font l'objet d'un débat
au sein de la communauté scientifique
car aucune entreprise spécialisée dans
l'agriculture cellulaire n'a encore
relever le grand défi
[Musique]
celui de la production à grande échelle
dans d'immenses bioréacteur au delà de
la rhétorique la biologie a des limites
pour ricardo san martin chercheur
émérite à l'université de californie à
berkeley
les contraintes de la biologie limite la
capacité des cellules à se multiplier
lors d'une production industrielle il ya
une limite au nombre de cellules qu'on
peut cultiver dans un réacteur
elles viennent à manquer d'oxygène et ne
peuvent pas croître
malgré tout les projets d'élevage en
laboratoire se multiplient et s'étendent
là où on ne les attendait pas
les produits de la mer on parle
maintenant d'aquaculture cellulaire
[Musique]
san diego 7 décembre 2019 la journée
marque un tournant dans l'histoire d'une
jeune entreprise californienne
le grand patron de blue n'alloue procède
au dévoilement officiel de sa toute
première création journal ou a réussi à
produire du filet de poisson directement
à partir de cellules de la technique
utilisée dans les laboratoires de blue
n'alloue est similaire à celle utilisée
pour fabriquer la viande artificielle la
chair de poisson a été cultivé en
quelques semaines à partir de cellules
souches de thon jaune blue n'alloue à la
prétention si la culture à grande
échelle fonctionne de pouvoir donner un
répit aux océans
on sauve la planète et on permet aux
stocks de poissons de se rétablir
c'est bon pour blue n'alloue prévoit
commercialiser son poisson d'ici deux
ans bien au fait de l'appétit des
consommateurs pour des produits de la
pêche durable est convaincu du potentiel
de l'aquaculture cellulaire les
investisseurs sont au rendez vous
you can get est clean air act
le produit est plus sain il n'y a pas de
pathogènes de mercure de virus varicelle
énorme
[Musique]
mais au delà du battage médiatique et
des investissements à coups de millions
c'est l'épreuve du temps qui démontrera
ses projets de cultures en laboratoire
tienne la route
[Musique]